une salle conquise une unité affichée
ump ou du modem rassembler pour ces
départementale nous avons réussi à faire
une trêve est l'unité de la droite du
centre jusqu'au modem de toutes les
sensibilités de la droite qui sont
réunis aujourd'hui pour gagner les
cantons qui sont jusqu'à présent réputée
ingagnable je pense à trappes
je pense à guyancourt il ya des
challenges importants j'en citerai que
trois l'emploi le transport
l'environnement et la solidarité envers
les plus démunis
et là je pense qu'il faut qu'on renforce
nos actions falloir qu'on soit mal un
inventif créatif innovant
c'est un exercice difficile l'union être
capable de trouver des candidats communs
mais ça nous paraissait à lui dit à
l'ump une nécessité parce que
l'essentiel est en jeu l'avenir des
usines
la crainte pour ce scrutin l'abstention
et le choix du vote du front national
alors que l'avenir des départements
n'est pas clairement défini leurs
compétences non plus pour les électeurs
ils sont assez perdu des compétences qui
ne sont pas encore fixées par la loi et
dans un scrutin qui manifestement du mal
à toucher les citoyens il faut leur dire
aux citoyens que c'est très important
parce que c'est leur proximité
quotidienne qu'elle soit sociale qu'elle
soit territoriale qu'elles soient les
collèges où qu'elle soit par exemple on
le sait maintenant l'aménagement des
routes
l'ump et ses partenaires ont détaillé
leur programme pour ces départemental
avec un volet social en direction des
demandeurs d'emploi la mise en place par
exemple d'une auto école sociale et
d'une halte garderie pour les parents en
recherche d'emploi il a aussi été
question d'innovation et du
développement du numérique dans les
établissements scolaires des
propositions qui devront donc convaincre
les électeurs pierre bédier de son côté
a appelé à la mobilisation générale
l'appel du 3 mars sera-t-il entendu
réponse dans les
22 mars